[Music]
in most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a while and I can tell
you because I've been doing it for a
while that in the old days it was mostly
technical with a little bit of content
sprinkled in so for argument's sake
let's say 80 20 80 % of what an SEO
needed to learn how to do had to deal
with you know you know your meta tags
your metadata you know CMS systems you
can bottle blah de blah de blah de blah
and oh by the way yeah you need some
content on the page well here we are a
long time past that and if this you you
look sure this slide here for example
this is the latest guidance from Google
on the kind of content they want and if
you look through the list here most of
the items on it are technical and
frankly most of it is content and if you
think about it what this means is is
that the job description for SEO has
changed dramatically particularly
beginning with the Panda update but then
including the penguin update and then
hummingbird and pardon me more and more
and more SEO s had better be interacting
with the people who are creating quality
content engaging content credible
content useful content it's not enough
just to put keywords in the right places
anymore on pretty thin content that
won't get you where you want to go so
again different paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in SEO frankly
need each other and they may or may not
recognize it in your organization but
you know it's a starting point this is a
conversation you you probably need to
have content marketing is complex it
often overlaps with other elements
Marketing the the most typical overlaps
are with social media marketing and SEO
and they're probably already are in your
organization those kind of groups the
SEO s may be on one floor and the social
media marketing people may be in a
different building you know whatever but
the new success formula it says we got
to get all those folks to the same table
now we may have to do it virtually we
may have to use you know webinars in
order to hold those kind of meetings who
knows but the point is is that you know
the world is shifting and organizational
structures need to shift with it and
again you know that's not something you
can change tomorrow but that is
something that will evolve over time and
for what it's worth it turns out that
let's just say the people who were in
SEO they may or may not admit it at
first but they absolutely need to work
with the people in content marketing
why because basically after Panda and
Penguin the rules shifted and it's less
about your title tag and it's most
mostly focused now on the quality of
your content and whether that content is
link worthy which means it's really
compelling content it's remarkable
content that's content that's going to
get people to link to it because wow
that's you know and that's not
necessarily part of the skill set that
was required to be a successful SEO five
years ago or ten years ago so again you
got to get these folks to the table
they've got to work together you know
and and again that means the
organizational structure probably needs
to shift and the same is true with the
social media marketing folks
you know they went out and their initial
goals and objectives were you know get
lots of likes you know get lots of fans
get lots of views gets lots of Twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave us and
so we used it to measure success well it
turns out none of those measures
actually measure real success because
they're focused on being successful on
the platform boy I have lots of fans as
opposed to being successful in business
Wow that generated lots of leads and
sales so there is a real real
discrepancy between let's just say the
center of gravity okay it's not Facebook
you're not going to make a lot of money
on Facebook you know let's just not set
up to do business you've got to get
those folks that you've engaged in
Facebook to your website where they can
buy something and that's a you know
radical shift for all the folks who are
in social media marketing to say wait
wait timeout but that's not what I was
told a couple years ago and the answer
is that's correct
what we've learned over time is that
being engaging is useful if it's
harnessed to a benefit and I'll tell you
in most organizations the social media
marketing people are under cloud because
they aren't delivering business benefit
and they too need to learn to work with
the content marketing people in order to
do that and in some cases they may not
be creating the right kind of content
that actually generates leads and sales
as opposed to you know is inexpensive to
create to get my next fan or my next
Twitter follower so the key metrics here
are no longer how many likes or comments
or
years did you get that's nice but how
many sales leads did you generate or
what percentage of those converted into
sales that's a radical change but again
it helps when the social media marketing
people are at the table with the content
marketing people hey once you become an
expert in digital marketing then
subscribe to the simply learned Channel
and click here to watch more such videos
turn up and get certified in digital
marketing click here